Hello everybody and welcome to week two of the biotoxid series
This week we're going to be talking about virus. It is what virus is due to your body
Hopefully you listen to the bacteria would last week. We're going to get a little bit into it a little critter
So a virus works different than a bacteria. It gets into a cell. It needs a host
So viruses can't live very long their own. They need to enter into a host
That's how they replicate inside of a cell
So I remember we talked about that most bacteria do not have the ability to infiltrate a cell. They're smaller
They can't get across the cell bed braid
Excuse me, the bacteria are larger. It can't get across the cell bed braid except that
Grab negative bacteria many of them can so a virus is the all of the viruses go inside the cells
They go inside the cell and that's how they replicate inside the cells. Now normally what a virus goes inside of a cell
There's a little marker that the cell gives off of the outside of the cell bed braid. So it's kind of like
Let's say if a big robber goes into a bake and he's going to rob the bake and he's got a gun. He says I want all your buddy
And there's a button underneath the counter that the teller pushes and it sends a secret alarm to the
police telling the police to come and arrest the robber what he leaves the bake well
That's kind of what the marker is on the outside of the cell bed braid. So the virus enters the cell the
The cell pushes this little red button underneath its counter and this little marker comes outside the cell telling the
Immune system that it is been infiltrated. So it tells the immune system that this bad guy is in here trying to replicate
tried to
kill us and
Because normally you look at this cycle the virus gets in there replicates inside the cell and then liberates itself by basically
Destroy the cell for the inside out the cell dies, but then a whole bunch of different baby viruses come out
if that
Cell marker is able to notify a
Macrophage a killer cell of your immune system that it has been infiltrated
Then literally the Macrophage that big giant white blood cell killer cell will surround the entire cell and it golf it
Kill the cell, but also kill the virus. That's how you kill viruses
So we're talking about that in a little bit, but you you need that good white blood cell that
Macrophage responds to be able to kill that virus
So it doesn't do exactly what you see on this slide
So
Because normally a virus again, there's another picture and gets inside the cell and it explodes itself out
a whole bunch of little baby viruses and it destroys the cell well your body will rather sacrifice that cell
That's going to die anyhow by surrounded it with the macrophage and killing it
It gets worse though because some viruses get inside of a cell. Let's say this is cardiovascular disease
But I said that H. Pylori is one of the major causes of cardiovascular disease
Well, there's several viruses that are also major causes of cardiovascular disease and here's a nice little picture
It exactly what takes place the virus or whatever the pathage it is this case of virus gets inside the
Intimolighted cell that intimolighted is that red
Lighty that you can see in this picture where there's a whole bunch of little different bugs and
viruses and bacteria while a virus gets inside that intimolighted it starts to reproduce and your body
Creates literally a blister underneath that intimolighted that gets bulged into the lumen of the vessel
Because it's creating this inflammatory response and then cholesterol actually tries to plaque over that
Balged blister that's blistered into that
Where the blood flows that lumen of the vessel and then cholesterol gets the name of be the bad guy
It's really that cholesterol's fault at all. It's not this giant cholesterol plaque
It's an inflammatory response due to a pathogen in the intimolighted of the vessel
We'll talk a lot about that because we have a I have a whole series of presentations at cardiovascular disease and how you can take care
of it from a natural approach, too
But this is actually what takes place in a one single slide the viruses of major cause of cancer as well
Because it infiltrates the cell it can
Replicate in the cell it damaged the DNA so that the DNA now you have an epigenetic cause of cancer
So the DNA it changes the replication cycle the cell starts to replicate
So in that case, it doesn't kill the cell it causes a change of the DNA
So that it's in a rapid replication phase. That's what cancer is so it's replicating replicating replicating the cell that is
Acty-like it's most do let's say if it's a liver cell. It's acting not acting like a liver cell. It's just in a rapid replication phase
virus changes the DNA
Viruses also could be responsible this picture
talks about a bacteria starting to infection, but
Any of these that we're talking about could be what could be in an inflammatory cycle. So it's this
vicious cycle of inflammation that
Just continues to go on and on so in this case the lung tissue is infected by a
virus or bacteria
Inflammation is at the at the site the inflammation is actually a TH water response tried to kill the virus
Maybe it's systems try to attack it, but it the this the virus is intruscellular
So I remember I said that what a virus infiltrates the cell that marker goes up on the side on the outside of the cell
Well, here's the bad news. There are certain viruses and certain bacteria both H. Pylori and
Borrelia
Lyme disease are two of those bacteria that have the ability to disable that marker
So it's almost like they're a really smart big robber who already cut the phone line so that that tellers
Just keeps pushing the red button and no police come because the just the phone line has been disabled
Well, they are responsible for causing then this just this chronic vicious inflammatory cycle
So there's an infection the uid systems try to kill it can't find it causes all this inflammation
The the
Bacteria virus then goes extra cellular goes into another cell starts to replicate it there the immune system fires
tries to kill it can't find it is just this constant vicious cycle
If that's in the lung you could get all sorts of problems with it if it's in the brain you got a really bad problems
Because you got this constant wrapped up infection
In the brain that your immune system is unable to kill and you just got this
This inflammation that just goes in cycles
So this person has memory lapses that maybe a day for a few hours
They feel kind of almost back to normal and then they lost their memory yet
It's just horrible vicious thing that you see with chronic Lyme MS
Epstein issues that are chronic viral or chronic grabbed negative bacterial infections
How do you kill a virus? What's kind of like killing a zombie? Sometimes that's a gross picture about it
The zombies but it is if they're very very difficult to kill their
Antiviral agents but they have a lot of side effects so I I never would recommend
Taking an antiviral that's just be so there's just way too many side effects that are coming out all the time
But antivirals
Eating a good diet to boost your immune system is the way to do it
So you got to get to the macrophages you need a strong enough TH water response to kill these things
There's a ton of antiviral supplements out there. I love this abutabary especially for kids it tastes good
It's got elderberry syrup in it and a bunch of other things. It's just a great thing
Abutotode is a is a
Supplement with a bunch of different things in a lot of medicinal mushrooms in there
We have our own medicine a mushroom product that we use a lot for patients
You could also kill it directly with like colloidal silver
Hydroproxide and a best different things like that that could kill a virus
And from direct contact
Obviously the best way is to live a healthy lifestyle
So that's what we want to promote all the time making sure you get enough sleep, but you're eating good food and
etc
so
That's it about viruses next week. It's about bold. Yeah, that's going to be a long one. So
Keep your shorts tight tight because we got a lot to go over. All right, Dr. Cutters. Thanks. I'll see you next week